welcome back to me rock stars I'm Erik
Bosse and contagion the 2011 thriller
about the fictional NTV one pandemic is
unsurprisingly the film that everyone is
rewatching at the moment maybe because
all new movies are delayed along with
Walt everything like HBO's Chernobyl or
great disease outbreak stories contagion
is an anxiety inducing biological
disaster horror with terrifying
scientific plausibility science that
when if Paltrow spends most of the movie
donating her body to these stories show
us how the scariest threat is the way
people lose their minds so I am gonna
break down just how realistic contagion
is the real-world scenarios it's based
on so that we're learning the right
lessons from this and hopefully a bit
less likely to make the mistakes the
characters in this fictional world do I
should also say that I am NOT a medical
expert and for up-to-date details on our
current situation please please please
consult the CDC website in the WHI
website the film opens with our patient
zero index case Beth Emhoff Gwyneth
Paltrow on day two of the outbreak now
the movies final sequence will show us
day 1 but here director Steven
Soderbergh and screenwriter Scott burns
are already giving us a visual roadmap
for how contagion will be a different
outbreak film than other less realistic
and I would argue less scary examples in
the genre this movie starts out with one
of Hollywood's most glamorous faces
looking rough sweating copied eating
Airport bar peanuts very bad idea and
surberg uses some clever camerawork here
lingering on close-ups of inanimate
objects
the peanuts Beth's credit card the
touchscreen now we'll find out later
that the scientific term for these is
fomites shared surfaces where viral
infections can spread from one person to
another
these fomites are really the shark fin
in the water of the film the invisible
threat that Soderbergh returns to again
and again real-life experts have
compared the pandemic in this movie to
the current covered 19 situation and
they grade the movie's high for focusing
on fomites as opposed to you know zombie
bites but they do point out that the
turnaround time would actually need to
be longer more than a few days for the
virus to shed from Beth's respiratory
tract or saliva tube spread to anything
she's touching the fictional disease in
contagion is called ma vie one Burns and
Soderbergh conceived it while
researching the 2009 h1n1 flu pandemic
the 2003 SARS outbreak and others they
consulted with researchers like Larry
brilliant
known for his work in eradicating
smallpox Ian Lipkin whu-oh specialist
and author Laurie Garrett people who
have dedicated their lives to studying
real outbreak scenarios and conceiving
hypothetical nightmare situations like
the one presented in this film Beth dies
two days later mev one moves super fast
and that's a big part of its danger
infected characters don't have much time
after exposure to reacts educate
themselves self quarantine etc before
they accidentally pass it on to someone
else
by comparison Kovac seems to have a
longer incubation period at least longer
than a week a lot more time to recognize
symptoms and do something about it
another big difference appears to be the
mortality rates MeV has a mortality rate
between twenty and thirty percent and by
the end of the movie ends up killing
twenty-six million people worldwide
that's insanely high but not as high as
the 50 million people who died in the
real-life 1918 Spanish flu but it's
still very high kovetz mortality rate is
still being determined but as of March
3rd it mentioned it at 3.4 percent of
reported cases but again that number may
have changed by the time you're watching
this so do your own research contagions
disaster response is roughly accurate to
the real world
the w-h-o deploys epidemiologist dr.
Arantes to hong kong to try to identify
its source meanwhile the CDC deploys CIS
officer dr. Mears to the cluster region
in Minneapolis to try to contain it and
while this happens we get more terms to
understand this disease for every person
who gets sick how many other people are
they likely to infect we call that
number B R naught R stands for the
reproductive rate of the virus so in
contagion the R naught of MeV one starts
at two but then later jumps to for the R
naught of Koba 19 is estimated right now
to be at 2 to 2.5 and again that doesn't
make it deadlier it's just a lot more
infectious than the seasonal flu that
comes every year the movie also
introduces CDC scientist dr. Hextall who
breaks down the MeV for us he's in
colors the virus contains both bat and
pig sequences
and pig back attaches to the cell like a
key slipping into a lock somewhere in
the world
the wrong people met up with the wrong
back indeed the final scene of the film
reveals those near accidental day1
events Beth's mining company de force
did a jungle displacing some bats that
eats banana banana chunk drops in pig
pen pig eats banana pig ends up in
kitchen chef touches pigs mouth chef
doesn't wash his hands affects winneth
when it kills everyone M eveyone in this
way is similar to the nipple virus in
Malaysia in the late 90s which was
believed to originate from bats
displaced by deforestation and was
spread to humans from pigs screenwriter
Byrnes researched eco tones humans
invade remote areas and exposed the food
chain to microbes human immune systems
aren't biologically prepared for and our
current disease actually stems from a
family of beta corona viruses that all
have their origins in bats okay so in
the race to develop a vaccine Hextall
knows that it'll take months and months
and months of human trials and FDA
approval so she takes the enormous risk
and tests a vaccine strain on herself
and luckily it works this is apparently
based on physicist Barry Marshall who
inoculated himself with Helicobacter
pylori to prove it was the cause of
gastric ulcers and he won a Nobel Prize
in 2005 however experts say that this
action for vaccine development wouldn't
be effective or safe they would actually
take a lot longer to develop a real
vaccine and by the way a vaccine was
never developed for the nimpah virus the
genius of contagion is the way it
tackles the crisis with a large team of
people working in various different
fields disease outbreaks aren't problems
Brad Pitt's alone can solve it takes a
community of specialists working
together while the rest of us listen to
them and try not to freak out too much
the characters of this film are super
smart they make a lot of great heroic
decisions occasional bad decisions in
the least heroic among them is Allen
Crum weady a social-media influencer who
first breaks footage of an early
infected person and he uses his
following to spread conspiracy theories
and pedals snake oil cures like the
homeopathic treatment called forsythia
from Wheaties TV appearance in the movie
with CNN Sanjay Gupta played himself in
the film and now reporting on our
pandemic and the fact that recent
real-life social media posts have
referenced forsythia and chrome we D
character these all give the movie
Contagion a really eerie art reflecting
life feel but really the misinformation
spread by people like from we D is the
contagion of contagion indeed nothing
spreads like fear folks these disease
outbreaks are messy they're a bit scary
and yeah the looting of grocery stores
and pharmacies in the movie may echo
what you're seeing at checkout lines
this is just how humans react when we're
afraid but contagion is a cautionary
tale to take advice from sources beyond
social media like the CDC like the w-h-o
because those people are just a bunch of
nerds risking their lives to keep us
safe and healthy and they're
recommending 20 second hand washes no
face touching and social distancing that
should be good enough for us like I'm
pretty isolated here in the blue dungeon
anyway that's it actually a heads up
that new rockstars might have to make a
few production adjustments during this
period stay tuned for updates comment
down below with your thoughts follow me
Eddie a vos follow new rockstars and
subscribe to narakasura breakdowns of
everything thank you for watching bye
[Music]